on the boys season 2 finale stormfront
learns a very important lesson
never attempt to kill a junior soup's
mom right in front of them
after receiving a beating from kimiko
starlight and queen maeve
stormfront flies off to stop becca and
butcher from taking ryan to safety
unfortunately for stormfront seeing
someone choking his mom is enough to
trigger ryan's powers
and he uses his heat vision to blast off
her limbs leaving her seemingly near
death and
babbling in german given what fans know
about stormfronts it would seem safe to
assume she was spouting nazi rhetoric
but thanks to reddit's user radotan
stormfront's final words for season 2 at
least
homelander insists she's still alive in
an undisclosed location
have been revealed to be surprisingly
human according to radiotan
stormfront says this at the end of the
boys season 2 finale
her words translate to english as it was
so beautiful how the three of us sat
there in the shade of an apple tree
do you remember the day frederick chloe
had her arm stretched out of the car
window
we found the perfect spot by the river
in the shade of an apple tree it was the
first time chloe ate fresh apples
later when homelander and ryan are
talking stormfront adds these words
in english that means i was so happy it
was wonderful
i never wanted it to end it would appear
that in what stormfront believes to be
her final moments
she doesn't think back to her hateful
beliefs or the atrocities that she's
committed
instead she remembers a quiet day with
her husband and daughter
and she yearns to return to what she
sees as a simpler time
at first the scene's translation may be
viewed as the boys writers attempting to
humanize a truly despicable person
but in truth stormfront's final words
both reinforce the strong theme of
family that runs throughout season 2
and also act as a reminder of just how
twisted her world view is stormfront may
remember an idyllic day of lounging
under an apple tree as a perfect picture
family moment
but in reality she and her husband were
fighting for mass genocide and hateful
racist ideas
whether she calls herself lady liberty
or stormfront she can't stop
trying to push an agenda of fear death
and hatred right from the beginning of
season 2
she shows her hand stormfront wants to
recreate the past
which for her means the early days of
nazi germany so it only makes sense that
she would retreat there while in a state
of shock
in an interview with variety showrunner
eric kripke discussed how the boys
season 2 puts the idea of family ties
right at its center whether it was
butcher confronting just how similar he
is to his father
or stormfront reminiscing to starlight
about her mother adele the relationships
between parents and their children was a
recurring theme throughout the season
but kripke having ryan rather than
kimiko or starlight be the one to end
stormfront's reign of terror was about
bringing that theme full
circle he said what we kept coming back
to is that we really needed to
demonstrate how powerful ryan was
and still have starlight and kimiko and
maeve get a certain visceral
satisfaction
with what they're doing but have the
final ending be really wrenching and
emotional and personal so we felt like
going back to how we really opened the
season
which was that it's really about family
and the question of can they survive it
you just tried things and that felt like
it really resonated the most
ultimately kripke described butcher's
dad as a demon on his shoulder
and becca as his humanity thankfully for
ryan butcher's humanity wins out when he
decides to keep his promise
to protect the boy for the moment butch
is resisting his father's legacy of
violence
and he's hoping that thanks to becker's
influence ryan will be able to do the
same where homelander
ryan's biological father is concerned
eventually everything comes back to the
theme of family on the boys
even for characters as monstrous a
stormfront and homelander
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite shows are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss
a single one